hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my Gammons and series so
last time we took we talked about
cameras and specifically the theory
behind cameras and we planned all of
that out you guys haven't seen that
video definitely check it out I gave you
guys a homework of trying to work this
out yourself so hopefully you've done
that if you haven't yet stop this video
go back and watch that one really have a
go because this series is all about
trying to teach you guys how to make
game engines and how they work and
you're not gonna learn anything unless
you actually do this stuff for yourself
rather than just copying down what I do
so definitely do that
if you haven't already I want to thank
all the patrons that made this series
possible patreon home for Steph the
Cherno is how you can support this
series thank you so much to everyone who
is supporting because that's what makes
it stuff possible and I'm so grateful to
all of you if you want videos early or
you want access to super advanced source
code that I've already written for this
engine check out the link in the
description pad on patreon and compos -
there churner ok cameras we've done all
the theory we know how they work let's
just dive in and go into the sea bass
class code and actually implement them
ok so what we did two episodes ago is we
created this render oh and we had render
a begin scene we had render a submit we
had render and scene we had all of this
stuff and last episode we learned about
all of the theory behind that so we
don't even cover that again today we've
done that in the last video which is
awesome because it means that we know
exactly what to do right so we need some
kind of way first of all let's just deal
with the camera side of things before we
begin submitting that data to the
renderer we need a camera right so what
is the camera it's a view matrix and
it's a projection matrix let's create
some kind of class to store all of that
since that renderer I'm going to add a
new item it's gonna be a header file I'm
gonna call it orthographic camera dot H
I just wanna be really explicit about
what kind of camera this is because
we're also going to have of course a
perspective camera or some kind of
camera that we can move in the future as
well so for now though this is just
going to be an orthographic camera now
that make things easier we are going to
kind of wrap the creation of this so
what you'll see me do in a minute and I
just want to include GLM yeah what we're
actually going to do is
orthographic camera I mean I didn't have
to call the file orthographic camera
because I could have just put all the
cameras in one file so that may have
been a mistake
but it's a cable tape that's the
explicit for now when we create an
orthographic camera and we get this
constructor I don't want to take you in
like a projection matrix we could write
this could just be such as in generic
camera class that it just like works
directly on projection matrix interview
matrix but I want to make this a bit
more fun a bit more flexible so what
we'll do is we'll just kind of take in a
flirt that's going to be like our left
essentially a flow that's going to be
our right effort it's gonna be bottom
and a flow that's gonna be top so this
is exactly what a what an actual
orthographic matrix wants write it once
basically be bounce now an orthographic
matrix is a matrix that instead of
having like a frustum it has like
because essentially just like a
rectangular prism that is like it's a
picture like a cube but it can be like a
rectangle and we're defining kind of the
left-right bottom top and there's also
near and far bounds but typically for
orthographic rendering like negative one
for Nia and one for Phi is fine that's
the defaults we're gonna use so we're
not gonna actually take them in here if
you wanted to you could make this a bit
more powerful by providing that API but
I'm not gonna bother because we don't
really have a use case for it and this
stuff is also somewhat temporary
probably and will be rewritten okay so
what do we actually need in terms of
data well we know what we need in terms
of data we need a map for that's our
projection matrix and we need a map for
this our view matrix okay now we
actually need to keep track of where the
camera is like the position of the
camera and all that as well now we don't
want to do this inside the view matrix
because what we'll do is like once per
frame essentially when we calculate
where our camera is we want to count
recalculate this view matrix this has to
be the inverse of like the actual
transformation matrix of the camera
right that's what the view matrix is so
we could have another matrix as actually
the transformation matrix but of course
you could just invert the inverted
matrix to get your original matrix back
so that's something we can do as well
but essentially what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna keep track of the position by just
using
position right and in terms of the
rotation I mean we could like keep track
of the rotation either either by using
like a back three of Euler angles or by
using like a quaternion or something
like that but you don't really rotate
orthographic cameras you can rotate them
like you know a long block the z-axis
but if you want to do a rotation like
that you can really just you know keep
rotation as a float and that's gonna be
fine and I'll initialize that to zero
okay
so there we have all the data that we
could possibly need really for
orthographic camera let's go ahead and
provide some functions for everything we
want so we want some kind of way to
retrieve these matrices right so we can
have a and I don't know like if you
wanted to you could also cache the view
projection matrix right so view
projection matrix because you might not
want you might you'd still need them
separated but you might also be
requesting this like very often and you
don't want to do them the multiplication
every time okay show yourself so you
could do that again this is up to you
because if you do that keep in mind you
are using 64 more bytes of memory for
this class
I don't know usually it's not a problem
though so we're gonna do that okay so we
have position right so let's go ahead
and make a set position function that
will actually let us set the position so
I'll take in a Const GLM BEC 3 which is
going to be position and then I'm just
gonna set M position to position so that
lets us actually position the camera
some way in the world right we'll also
do a set rotation which will just be a
flirt rotation so again this is going to
be Z rotation rotation along the z axis
because we don't really need any other
rotation for anthropic camera because
again this is basically a 2d camera
picture it that way you didn't really
rotate things along the X or the y axis
fatuity that's gonna give you weird
results that you probably don't want
again obviously if there's a no this is
an orthographic camera for like a 3d
modeling application you're making then
you still want to have you know XY & z
rotation but in this particular scenario
I'm picturing this as more of just an
orthographic
that specifically is for like 2d or 2d
rendering that's why I'm doing it this
way
and in 2d we only have one axis anyway
like I said we only have like two
dimensions so therefore rotation along
the z axis is all we can do okay so
that's that I also want to have getters
for this so float get position
I'm sorry not float canción back three
reference get position const return and
position right and then for rotation I'm
going to do the same thing so float get
rotation and oops this will be rotation
Const on what I want to type today
return M rotation okay wonderful so that
looks like a pretty solid API to me now
let's go ahead and actually create this
now when we do this stuff see this is
the thing when we do this stuff right
set we've got set position obviously we
don't have any ways of retrieving
matrices by the way but when we do set
position set rotation we probably need
to update the actual view matrix unless
we have some kind of update function
which does that for us so this again is
up to you if we're dealing with a camera
that's responding to mouse movements you
could implement an on update function or
even hook this up to the event system
and upon then you'll be recalculating
your matrices but what I'm saying is at
the moment our matrices do not get
recalculated so what we need to do is
create a function we could use on update
again but I won't this example which
will be recalculate the view matrix
right and recalculate view matrix is
basically going to be a function that we
call whenever we set something so when
we set rotation we want to recalculate
the view matrix when we set position we
want to recalculate the view matrix and
we want to do this by the way after we
set the value obviously so recalculate
view matrix because here I'm still
keeping this kind of in line and in one
line because it's not that big of a deal
but you know if you want to drop that
into a CPP file or anything like that
then that
be totally fine and appropriate okay so
this is what we've got we also need a
way to retrieve these things so very
easy I'm just gonna make a const GLM map
for get projection matrix const which
will return projection matrix right
again you could make setters for this at
this point you could really do whatever
you want you could just make them you
can make this a struct and have public
fields instead there's no I don't know
cameras are such a flexible you know API
usually that you can cause VP matrix B
projection matrix I like to be quite
explicit especially because this series
is about teaching you guys how this
stuff works so we'll do that okay view
projection matrix view matrix and
projection matrix good everything looks
pretty good to me now we can just make
this constructor that actually ended up
being the only thing in this file let's
include age said PCH and orthographic
camera namespace hazal go over here
we'll get rid of this namespace what
this is gonna do is actually make the
matrix right so projection matrix is
going to be basically a GLM orthographic
or author I think it's called
I forgot the actual I always forget
where this actually is so it looks like
it's in GLM extension like not four or
something so I think it's GLM GTC matrix
transform yep okay and then this takes
left right and you can see this actually
has a function that just takes bottom
top I think they've also got one that
takes near-far I'm not sure if we don't
let's just see if we go to this and we
look at what it does
let's take a look try and take a look
because this is quite hard to read of
what it actually did for near and far so
a little bit hard to see here but ortho
for the place where it's supposed to use
like near and far which for example is
here you can see it just uses a default
value of one so you could probably roll
with that but I still I'm gonna provide
negative one and one just so that we
actually know what those values are and
we're not relying kind of on GLM okay
that's like finally enough that's pretty
much it now we don't need to recalculate
view matrix here at all oh we actually
need that function not sure why visual
assist didn't make it recalculate B
matrix so this is something that happens
after we changed the actual transform
whether it be by setting the position or
setting the rotation so what we need to
do is calculate the actual matrix first
and I'll show you guys the whole kind of
code for this you could pop the
optimizer but not doing everything every
time but we're still going to do that
just the you guys can see how it works
so we have our transformation matrix now
what is this gonna be so we're gonna
take it's going to be position times
rotation so the first step is to take
the position and actually work out a
translation matrix from that so that's
just going to be GL GL M translate and
all this stuff is in that matrix
transform head on GL m translate we're
going to take a base matrix which is
gonna be the identity matrix like that
and then we're going to translate it by
a given vector now the vector is gonna
be positioned right so that's how we
kind of wind up with this then what
we're going to do is multiply it by
rotation so GLM rotate the math for that
we're going to be rotating is just again
an identity matrix and then the angle of
which we're gonna rotate it is going to
be rotation and then along which axis
we're gonna rotate it is gonna be GL M
vector 3 0 0 1 ok so there's that axis
now few ways of writing this I mean what
you could actually do technically
speaking is because this takes in a base
matrix you could actually break this up
into two lines so that you do you know
here transform equals rotate and then
which major you've kind of rotate the
transform matrix like this and you do
all that I don't like doing it that way
because it's just it's just to be
confusing to read I don't really like it
so what I usually end up doing is
something like this right
so and I've broken it up into two lines
so that you guys can see it more clearly
but basically we just we always use
matte four here right and we just do
translate in position that does the
translation matrix then we multiplied
ourselves manually by the rotation
matrix
I'll have to look in
performance to see if it's actually
better to just start with an actual
matrix instead of identity when we
create these matrices but to me this
actually just makes more sense because
we're basically just saying and I would
love it if GLM didn't take in this
matrix in the first place because then
we could just do translate position and
rotate you know a rotation like that and
that would be beautiful
but the API does that so that's just the
way it is okay cool and you are probably
supposed to use it by actually putting
in the previous matrix here but again
this kind of makes more sense
mathematically I guess because you know
starting from a other matrix and then
not knowing about multiplication order
or anything like that so that's how
transform matrix that's beautiful but we
need to invert it right so when we
actually set our view matrix what we
need to do is do GLM inverse transform
so we're taking our transform matrix
that were inverting it just like we
talked about in that theory video in the
last episode okay and that's it now we
obviously obviously also need to
calculate our view projection matrix
which is going to be in this case G LM
sorry just M projection matrix times M
view matrix alright and that's how view
projection matrix now I am I didn't
write it as a view projection matrix not
projection view matrix so I wrote a
drawer textile or row major style even
though it's like this so that might be a
bit confusing but remember GM is column
major because we're dealing with OpenGL
and it's based on OpenGL so we need to
do the multiplication this order not
disorder if you do it the other way
around it will not work correctly okay
so this is not what you want okay cool
I just don't do all that that should be
pretty much it right so every time we
change position or rotation we
recalculate this whole matrix cool
sounds good to me
let's go ahead and try and use this so
inside application we really should move
all this stuff into sandbox app I
probably should do that maybe in like a
mid week episode because I don't really
want to spend an episode on that anyway
so we'll do include hazel renderer
orthographic camera what I'll do is I'll
pop over into the header file and I'm
just gonna make and this doesn't have to
be like
this this doesn't have to be like a
reference like a shared pointer or like
a unique component or anything we can
literally just make this kind of on the
staff like that and then we'll have to
in the constructor actually specify some
values for it so we need the left and
right near and far all of that stuff so
we can just do minus 1 1 so we'll
actually feed it the same values that
are being used right now which is when
we don't provide any kind of matrix
okay so we have camera which provides
all that stuff let's not even move it we
don't need to move it by the way at the
moment just so you know the view matrix
so when we actually missed one thing
that we should have done um and that is
because if we request this view
projection matrix right now it's gonna
give us identity like it nothing Oh
actually I don't even know I think by
default it creates identity but it might
not to be honest I don't know if it
better create identity by default but
anyway if it doesn't we can just set it
just to be sure but anyway when you set
out anyway because we need to set this
view projection matrix right now to be
projection times view right so this
basically we need to run this code in
the constructor as well
so that we have a valid valid view
projection matrix and just to make sure
I will I can actually set view matrix to
one like that which will create an
identity matrix okay so that's done
great beautiful so back an application I
have a valid view projection matrix I
need to get it and actually put it into
my shader so how do I do that
well I use something called a uniform
and a uniform is basically just a per
draw call kind of value that I can
actually set to my shadow from the CPU
side so from the c++ side in this case
so the way that is accessed is we'll
create one in the vertex shader it's
just going to be written as uniform and
then the type which is map four and then
I like to use a yuan spa prefix just to
let us know that it's in uniform this is
going to be the view projection matrix
okay just your projection is fine and
then what we're gonna do is in GL
position we're going to multiply this
view projection by this position okay so
again in DirectX you kind of do it the
other way around
and you'd probably you wouldn't use you
probably using them all as well in
actual cell
but anyway in jail cell is just view
projection times the switch in this case
is our actual vertex position and
obviously this is just for this shader
so we'll copy that into the next shader
as well because we have a blue shader as
well so your projection and then B
projection times and that's it and you
can use uniforms anywhere you can just
write uniform you know uniform
Veck for color for example right and
then you can take in an actual color
into this and use that color say instead
of this color to give that that blue the
blue a rectangle any kind of color you
want okay anyway we've got that now how
do I actually set this though right so
what we need is some way to set that
uniform now we don't have that API
inside chedda yet so let's go ahead and
see how to set a 4x4 matrix so what we
do is we'll just make a function I'm
going to call this upload uniform mat
for right this makes sense we will
include GLM because we should know what
it is and then what we want to do is
take in a constant vlm math 4 which is
going to be our matrix I'll just create
an implementation from that now what we
well the first thing we need to do is
make sure that our program is actually
bound now I'm gonna assume that you do
that manually because if we want to
upload a whole bunch of matrices or a
whole bunch of uniforms we don't want to
keep binding and every time so I'm gonna
actually mandate that you actually bind
a pro bind this program before you
actually upload this matrix so this is
just going to the upload part but
basically we need to make sure that we
like you know GL use program first and
then we're gonna do GL uniform mate
matrix for F V now F means it's float
would be means is an array of floats
because obviously a matrix is 16-foot so
the first the first piece of information
here we have is a location so where on
earth is this matrix so to do that we
need to retrieve the actual location now
we've called a variable something we've
called it v+ we've called it you view
projection right so what we actually
want to do is retrieve that
and we can do that by calling GL and get
uniform location okay what we do with
this is we pass in the program which is
M render ID and then we pass in an
actual name so in this case it would be
you you know production matrix obviously
what I want to hard-code that so we're
just taking name and name will be a
Const STD string name and then we'll
take into matrix as well so this name
will copy that paste it into here this
is gonna be name this gives us some kind
of like result essentially it's gonna
give us an int I believe and the int
will just determine and if I go back to
here I can see it gives us an int yep
this int will determine whether or not
this is what we're on is valid so
because that's negative one it actually
means that it doesn't exist and we just
need to do name dot C string okay so
that's our location let's assume that
worked from now we at work probably next
episode maybe we might take a look at
uniforms in just a better way because
this video is about implementing the
camera we take an account so this is not
how many floats for giving us how many
matrices were giving we're giving one
matrix so we write 1 transpose is
whether or not we should transpose the
matrix so if you were in row major
ordering because you were using like a
row major math library or like a DirectX
maps or something like that like that
you just need to transpose your matrix
you would just type in GL true and it
would transpose it for you
raising column major Maps already column
major matrices so we just type in jail
false umm and then finally this is a
pointer to the value um
numerous ways to retrieve this from GL
but usually I use GL m value pointer MN
matrix and that gives us back that gives
us back an actual point and now you know
what to use value point oh and you need
to include it and I have no idea where
it is GLM GGC maybe value pointer or or
is it g TX value point I don't know
where this thing is man okay so it's
actually I googled it's GL m type point
up so thanks
anyway there we go okay and then we do
that that's how we upload a uniform
Malfoy into our shader so now that we
know that what we can do is and we're
not going to upload it here we're gonna
actually upload it before we draw okay
what we want to do is just to test this
out Elise is once we bind our shader we
want to upload upload a uniform mat for
and this is gonna be our camera guess
view projection matrix okay and then
obviously we need to give it a name and
what do we call our uniform u underscore
view projection matrix so we just put
that into the string like that and
that's how we actually set that variable
in our shader we're gonna do the same
thing for this so shader and an upload
uniform map for done now if we run this
we should see hopefully the exact same
result as before I know that we're
binding the shader first here so let's
go ahead and see what we get we actually
got a ton of build errors so that's
fantastic camera is unknown that's
because I think we included camera into
CPP file whereas we should have done
that in here so we'll just leave that
here try and build again and hopefully
it worked this time all right and build
was successful here's us running it and
you can see we got the same result now
that's great let's try and change this
matrix and see if we actually achieved
anything so back in our CPP file I'm
gonna try to make this a lot bigger
right so it's like negative 1 right now
sure what I'm gonna do is actually make
it bigger and if I make it bigger if I
just open Photoshop here and just draw
with the mouse um this was our current
screen right this was negative 1 this
was positive 1 what I'm gonna do is make
it bigger right so what that's gonna do
if I set it to negative 2 is suddenly
it's gonna be like this big right what
that actually means in practice is that
my vertex positions which if we go back
here for a second my vertex positions
used to be like negative 0.5 to 0.5 for
the triangle if my vertex positions were
that right it means that this was 0 0 so
this was like negative 0.5 the triangle
looked like this right and
that's awful but you kind of get the
point the triangle looked like that or
whatever I think it actually started
like that if I make this negative too
suddenly that negative 0.5 is actually
going to be like more here so the
triangle is gonna be like that maybe
everything's gonna be smaller because
I've made the left and right bounds and
the top and bottom bounds of my screen a
lot bigger so if I go over here into
this and modify it so that is negative 2
to 2 and negative 2 to 2 on both X&Y
everything should be smaller because
what I've done is just made the bounds
bigger so the camera can kind of see
more in this scenario and you can see
there we go everything's a lot smaller
now one thing that I've hated since
we've kind of started this is the actual
aspect ratio of this right so obviously
if we look in our actual code here you
can see that we're defining a square
right this is a square it's negative
0.75 to positive 0.75 in every axis it's
a square but it's rendering as a
rectangle why because the matrix of
course our projection is from negative 2
to 2 or negative 1 to 1 in both of these
however this window is not square if we
make the window square like that I mean
we haven't said that up properly but you
can see it kind of gets it kind of looks
right in the preview before we actually
remember this so what we want to do is
actually set this actual like projection
matrix to be the same aspect ratio of
our actual scene right now it doesn't
have to be like you know in pixels or
anything like that it just has to be the
right aspect ratio now clearly we've
made a window I think that's 1280 by 720
that's a 16:9 aspect ratio so what I
actually could do is just do something
like negative one point six two positive
one point six on the x axis and then
negative point nine two positive point
nine on the y axis and now this
obviously is gonna be 16:9 right so
let's go ahead and try with this and we
should get an actual square square and
you can see that this square is now
square now this triangle looks very tall
now and not as nice but we're actually
rendering a square which is pretty cool
so I'm just gonna leave it at that
now API wise when
perfect right because what we're having
to do like we've got the result we want
100% but you know begins teens not
taking a camera like we kind of decided
we would in the previous episode so what
I'm gonna do is hop over here into the
renderer and actually make this take in
a camera now how we taking a camera
again I did say that we can take in like
a reference to a camera or we can copy
the camera or we can do whatever I
definitely don't want to copy the whole
camera class because if we look at the
whole camera class it's like for
matrices have that like a three
component vector on the floor so it's
like four matrices plus a full component
vector essentially that's too much like
I don't want to copy all that data if
anything we just need a copy projection
matrix so what I could do is you can
begin scene I could just take in
essentially a reference to an
orthographic camera it doesn't really
matter where it comes from but I'm
taking in a reference to it so it could
be from a pointer from a shared pointer
anywhere because what I kind of want to
do in this case is maybe just copy that
matrix right you'll see that will
actually kind of do more than that there
anyway that's kind of what I want to do
fourth or rather camera I could just
actually also have a shared pointer and
then get a reference that in scene but
as I mentioned that's not really the
design we want to go for at least not
right now
so orthographic camera is gonna be
inside a begin scene okay so what that
means is that and I'll have to include
this so include orthographic camera what
that means is that when we begin scene
now we have to actually submit a camera
which is exactly what we want the next
step is we need to also bind the
appropriate shader and upload this
uniform at fault what that means is that
when we submit something for rendering
now we need to be aware of what shader
it should be rendered with right so what
that means is that this function now
needs to take in information about the
material of this geometry right so
basically in this case all we have is a
shader right and the material is just a
shader on a set of uniforms and that
will be something stored in a mesh so
whenever in other words in the future
this will just take in basically a Const
reference like a shared pointer right to
an actual mesh I said references in like
a ref counted object
but basically it's just gonna take in
like a reference to a mesh and that's it
but right now we don't have materials
obviously with meshes already kind of
that so we just taking a vertex array
and then we're actually going to take in
a shader as well so const STD shared a
pointer shader okay and that's going to
be the shader with which we render so
i'll copy this into here and i don't
know if you want taking the trader first
or the trade a second or whatever you
want to do it's kind of up to you when
we put shader over here this is
temporary and anyway so i'm not putting
too much thought into it but basically
what we want to do here is actually bind
the shader doesn't matter in opengl
doesn't matter if you do it first a
second and then we want to actually
upload that camera but the cameras here
and this whole class is static so we
have no way of storing it so how is that
going to work
well again traditionally you need some
kind of backing data that the renderer
has we don't have anything like that at
the moment you could if you wanted to so
it's kind of up to you how you do this
but basically what i'm gonna do is make
a case i want to make a struct for the
same data right and then this is going
to have in this case a projection matrix
so GLM matte for view projection matrix
again and i'm gonna have a static scene
data pointer now this is totally up to
you how you want to do this this is like
I don't know we're gonna revise this
design in the future because we suddenly
run into a renderer there's not a
hundred percent static but needs to
persist with the state so it's up to you
how you end up doing that so now we're
just gonna do it this way scene data is
going to be basically something that's
gonna live for the entire duration of
our actual of our actual renderer right
and we're only gonna have one of them so
it's totally fine to just keep allocate
that there and leave it as be so what
happens here is when we begin a scene
what I want to do is access scene data
and set the view projection matrix
the camera yet view projection matrix
okay and that's kind of the same data
and then finally over here after we bind
this we want to upload that uniform mat
for it's gonna be going into you a blue
projection and it's going to be obtained
out of your projection matrix okay let
me just double check yeah it is your
projection I thought I might have maybe
possession matrix okay that's done all
right
okay that's as simple as it is to just
set this up we need to take in a shader
and we've taken a vertex array what I
might do is actually I've decided that
and I wanted to do that I know why I
didn't but I actually do want to have
the shadow first because we can't really
like a vertex raise great we're
submitting that but we need to know the
shed is not more important I think than
the actual geometry data you know way
for this because the shader kind of
specifies how we're rendering and then
what were rendering so I just kind of
like that way or order of things more
okay so in here we submit the shader
first so blue shader and then we submit
the actual vertex array and then over
here again we submit the shader and then
the vertex array and then guess what
this disappears this now does not need
to be done so we have a begin scene we
have two submissions and we have an end
scene and that's it and it's gonna
respond to our camera and everything's
gonna be amazing so let's just run this
code and see what we get
okay and as you can see we get the same
result as last time isn't that cool so
that is basically it you can see that
really all we do is we just create a
camera with a particular orthographic
projection now we didn't do step
position or anything let's do that for
fun so what I'll do is I'll set em
camera I'll set the position yeah we
should test that out for sure I'll set
the position to be offset a bit so we
don't want to go too far maybe 0.5 in
both x and y right because if we go too
far everything's gonna be off the bounds
so let's just set our cameras position
to 0.5 here and see what happens okay
and as you can see we moved the camera
now where do we move the camera when we
move the camera point five point five so
we move the camera right and up and you
can see that this has moved down right
down and left which is the opposite so
obviously our inverting is working
correctly and then finally what I want
to do is actually set the rotation
so we'll say camera set rotation right
and it might be better to do that
without setting the position actually
just so that it doesn't rotate somewhere
else because if we rotate both and it's
gonna be a bit off the screen but we all
basically just wrote out everything 45
degrees and see what that gives us okay
so it's giving us nothing which is quite
strange so we should probably diagnose
that first of all I very stupidly I
think even consider the rotation in
terms of whether it would be in radians
or not obviously I think it will be in
radians so we should actually cast this
into radians and then we have our
translation and our rotation so that
should actually all be correct let's go
ahead and try that out again and see
what we get okay so yet again nothing
that's always fun let's go ahead and try
and debug this one of the first things
I'm gonna do to debug it is actually
trying to set the rotation to a pretty
small value like 0.5 I also want to take
a look at the actual camera API here to
see that I'm actually setting everything
correctly so yes rotations being set to
rotation and I am in fact recalculating
the view matrix so that's all correct
yeah that's that's quite strange but if
we set it to a low value we should see
no we actually see nothing that is quite
peculiar okay so let's just start by
diagnosing all the numbers whenever
something like this happens it's really
important to actually dive in and see
what the numbers that you're getting in
your matrix are and this can be hard for
some people who aren't too experienced
with matrices but I should be fine so
recalculate view matrix is where
everything happens let's see what our
serve our rotations 0.5 our position is
okay
our position is not set so I guess GLM
doesn't actually initialize things like
at all I think maybe I was under the
impression that that would just get set
to zero zero zero but it didn't so
that's a bit of an issue this float of
course we did actually set a zero so
that's good but position doesn't get set
to zero so that would be the issue so we
need to make sure that we do that sir
how come when we hit a position just
make sure that I set that to zero I
might be able to just do that
or I cannot I'll just do that and now if
I go back here again change this to be
45 instead to make it a bit better let's
just launch this and now everything
should just work I think okay and as you
can see everything is on a 45 degree
angle now we should be able to move the
camera slightly as well with no issue at
all it's important to test that both
like translation and rotation actually
works so we'll try and move it like
maybe one or something one might be too
much the 0.5 again we'll try and move at
point 5 whoops
make sure that we give this as a three
component vector and it should just work
okay so you can see that we've both
rotated and translated our camera and
everything seems to do working correctly
of course is doing that the rotation
still is correct it's not rotating
around the new origin point it's doing
it in the right order which is really
important so there we go we've got
rotation and we've got translation and
we've got cameras a bit of homework for
you guys if you want to do something
yourselves is actually try and make this
position and rotation stuff try and
control the camera using like the WASD
case or the arrow case or something like
that so you can hook on into events and
then set positions or rotations based on
that so see if you couldn't do that for
homework that would be quite a little
good little exception exercise but
summarize you can see how clean
everything is we're now beginning a
scene with a camera and then we're
submitting everything they get the
shader the shader uses the view
projection matrix to actually set the
camera data right obviously right now
we're binding and setting shaders for
everything so if I render a whole bunch
of these with the same shader it's gonna
set it every time so what we won't
actually want to do obviously is when we
submit we want to store the shader and
the vertex array any other geometry in
like a list and then kind of you know
bash them together essentially but for
now you can see that this kind of simple
way of doing things
works wonderfully so there we go that's
pretty much all there is to say about
cameras next time I do want to actually
maybe expand a little bit on how shader
uniforms work but it might not be really
quite necessary
I don't think I've I mean I haven't
covered uniforms at all in the game
engine series but they might not be
necessary just yet I think what another
better thing for us to explore
potentially might be this whole model
matrix thing so we'll see I'll still
make my decision based on what I think
is better but that is cameras okay I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did you can hit that like button you can
help support this series by going out at
patreon icon for safe
the churner if you haven't already huge
thank you as always to everyone who
helped support the series you can get
the next video a week early and you also
get access to the source code for hazel
head the hazel development branch where
I've done like a 3d scene with a PBR
ender and a whole bunch of other really
cool stuff animation is in there
everything is really cool next time as I
said maybe some graphics see things
maybe the model matrix kind of stuff
we'll see how this kind of ties in
together because of it there's a lot of
pathways or we could go down into to
make this stuff happen but you can see
that oh and I really want to have like a
midweek episode probably to just move
this stuff away from the application
class obviously an entry our actual
sandbox app so I'll probably do that as
well anyway I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]